how does alternating-current even work
if charges never go anywhere the answer
to this question rearranged all my
intuitions about circuits prepare for a
mind blow this episode was made possible
by generous supporters on patreon
hey crazies one thing you cannot do is
confuse the motion of charge with the
motion of energy they are not the same
thing let's define them both very
carefully electric current or just
current for short is the flow of
positive charge wait wait wait positive
charge yeah you can think Ben Franklin
for that too the timeline back in 1748
Ben Franklin stated two things about
electricity one ampere becomes negative
when rubbed and two current is the flow
of positive charge then a hundred and
fifty years later
JJ Thompson discovered the electron and
we realized we had a problem you'd think
we would have adjusted one of Franklin's
definitions but we didn't we doubled
down on them instead even though we know
negative charge is what moves in a
current we pretend like it's positive
charge moving in the opposite direction
human stubbornness will never cease to
amaze me anyway we have to live with it
now electric current is the flow of
positive charge and we measure it in
amperes or amps for short the energy
flow on the other hand is best described
by something like power that's basically
how fast the energy is being used and
its measured in joules per second watts
Giorgi for what anyway current and power
are related to each other since current
is charged over time and voltage is
energy per charge power is just current
times voltage it's a relatively easy
calculation but our original question
isn't really about amounts it's about
direction this equation tells us nothing
about direction but isn't the energy
carried along by charged particles what
won't the current and the power be in
the same direction well yes to the first
question but no to the second the
charged particles do have energy because
well everything has energy but that's
not the energy that's powering whatever
device trees
let's say for the sake of simplicity
it's just an incandescent lightbulb what
I'm about to explain will be true of
everything but we don't want to get
caught up in unimportant details on the
same note let's how our that light fall
using a simple battery the positive end
has a higher energy than the negative
end so if you give the charge as a path
they'll fall to the lower energy that's
what an electric current is over time we
know the energy in a battery goes down
as we use our devices it can cause sheer
panic when it's the battery in our
phones but this same thing happens with
the light bulb - the energy in the
battery goes down as the light bulb
emits heat and light the flow of that
energy is described by something called
the pointing vector no that's not a typo
it's named after John Henry pointing the
guy who came up with it it is a pun
though because it points in the
direction of energy flow
I love puns anyway here's the pointing
vector E is the electric field B is the
magnetic field and mu is just the
constant to make the unit's come out
right don't worry about that too much
that gives us the energy flowing through
an area every second a common use of
this vector is with light light is an
electromagnetic wave a disturbance in
electric and magnetic fields that
results in a flow of energy from a ball
that looks something like this but the
pointing vector is true for any electric
and magnetic fields not just the ones
you find in light what's the deal with
those fields again hmm I guess I could
do a cookie review charges affect the
electric field and moving charges affect
the magnetic field these fields are not
attached to the charge they stay
attached to space while the charge moves
if no charges are around the fields are
still there
they're just zero a similar thing
happens around a battery this battery
can be thought of as two equal but
opposite charges those charges will
affect the electric field but according
to the pointing vector we don't get an
energy flow without also having a
magnetic field the battery isn't going
to lose energy just sitting there it has
to be connected to something here's the
electric field around the battery again
drawn a little simpler if we connect
some wires and a light bulb that feel
will distort a little even though the
charge and that extra stuff is balanced
it still channels the field through
itself the field in those materials is
strong enough to push the charge along
now that there's a closed loop the
electric field will cause a steady
current and where there's moving charge
there's a magnetic field so now we have
an electric field and a magnetic field
according to the pointing vector we get
an energy flow but this cross-product
means the flow has to be perpendicular
to both fields
the flow of charge is the same direction
as the electric field which can't be the
same as the flow of energy according to
pointing the energy cannot flow in the
same direction as the charge wait what
exactly when I realize this it broke all
my intuitions about circuits but here's
what everything looked like when I put
it all back together if we zoom in and
one of the wires a little we've got a
strong electric field inside moving the
current along and a little electric
field outside we also have a magnetic
field inside and outside using the
pointing vector we get an energy flow
toward the center of the wire the energy
comes from the field outside the wire
wait didn't you say earlier that the
energy comes from the battery yeah but
but it happens indirectly inside the
battery the electric field points the
opposite way but the magnetic field
points the same way if we look at the
battery the same way we did the wire the
energy flows out of the battery and into
the field so the energy the wires and
light bulb gain from the field is the
same amount of energy that the battery
loses to the field the energy flow in
this circuit looks like this
it's cray-cray it doesn't even matter if
it's AC or DC with alternating current
or AC the current just moves back and
forth because the electric field keeps
switching direction but so does the
magnetic field if this changes direction
and so does this the two effects cancel
the energy flow maintains its direction
even in an AC circuit the energy flow is
out of the source and into the devices
how can that possibly be our AC
generators like miles away yeah but but
that's a totally fine
remember these fields are everywhere and
affected by all charges everywhere the
energy coming out of a power source
doesn't have to be the same energy going
into your devices conservation of energy
just says they have to be the same
amount if you calculate the amount of
energy flow across the surface of this
wire you will get exactly what you'd
expect for the power loss to heat in
light so how does the energy actually
flow in a circuit the energy that makes
a circuit work comes from the fields
around them a source of energy like a
battery just replenishes what gets used
and all the electric current does is
provide the mechanism we need to make
the energy flow sorry you as
mind-blowing as me right now please
share in the comments thanks for liking
and sharing this video don't forget to
subscribe if you'd like to keep up with
us and until next time remember it's
okay to be a little crazy the featured
comment comes from spaces where we
belong to who asked is when just a
little nudge to get the coil spinning no
no what we're not making perpetual
motion machines the induced current
actually resists the motion of the coil
so without the continued push from the
wind the coil almost immediately stops
anyway thanks for watching